at a Texas rally before thousands of
supporters US president Donald Trump's
celebrated the ceasefire the White House
has negotiated with Turkey by his own
admission he called his strategy
unconventional without spilling a drop
of American blood not one drop of
American blood
we've all agreed on a pause or a
ceasefire in the border region of Syria
and it was unconventional what I did I
said they're gonna have to fight a
little while sometimes you have to let
them fight a little while then people
find out how tough the fighting is but
outside the rally members of the Kurdish
American diaspora protested the
agreement we don't have much faith in
the ceasefire since it you asked Kurds
to push 20 miles away from the border
that's where the majority of the Kurdish
and Christian areas are so it's giving
Turkey everything that they're already
asking for so what kind of ceasefire is
in if you're asking one side to give up
everything in Washington congressional
Democrats are also criticizing the White
House decision to remove recent turkey
sanctions so Congress is promising its
own bipartisan sanctions against Turkey
in the coming days Senate Republicans
say the agreement abandons Kurdish
fighters allied with the United States
what we have done to the Kurds will
stand as a blood stain in the annals of
American history Trump supporters in
Texas are backing Trump's withdrawal of
US soldiers from Northeast Syria they
say US lives have been at risk for too
long I think if we would have left them
there they could have been involved or
in between some type of a firefight
between Turkey and the Kurds I think
it's time that we got out of the endless
wars over there and let them
they're all more we've taken out very
few men that were there and brought them
home but we still have a lot of our
young men over there so I think the
government was going to do that anyway I
don't think those few troops that came
out cause the problem President Trump
says the next five days of the ceasefire
will be critical but he's optimistic he
says president air Dewan is a gentleman
who just needed some tough love to reach
an agreement
Trump is promising to host air21 at the
White House next month
Kimberly helfen al Jazeera Dallas Texas